in this weird inverted world that we're
living in the criminals are actually the
victims who are the criminals well
obviously since you're Christians
they're the real problems these are
Christians in the middle class boy
they're dangerous and the FBI it's hard
to believe this that was their decent
FBI agents but the FBI as an
organization has joined in the hunt for
Christians and we have proof of it the
FBI is trying to manufacture crimes
against sincere Catholics the FBI's
Richmond field office recently published
an internal document promising to punish
quote radical traditionalist Catholics
and their ideology now just to make
something completely clear the Bill of
Rights prohibits the government
from weighing in on sectarian or
religious questions they don't get to
decide whether your religion is good or
bad they have to be agnostic on it
but the FBI has decided if you're too
sincere about Catholicism you're a
criminal
the document cites obvious lies from the
fascist and dishonest Southern Poverty
Law Center several times now we only
have this memo because it recently
suspended FBI agent called pile seraphin
brought it to the public and we're
grateful that he did Kyle thank you so
much for joining us tonight this it's
hard to believe this is even real this
is one of those what was your reaction
when you saw this
well my reaction is predictable I mean
I'm a Catholic number one and I think
it's appalling it's one of those things
that when the government has gotten to
the point where you talked about our
Second Amendment rights and those defend
our first amendment rights to practice
our religion particularly the way that
we want to
um I'm friends with people who love the
Latin Mass I I grew up in a Traditional
School where I actually learned Latin in
fifth and sixth grade and all the way
through high school and um it doesn't
seem reasonable but it is the state of
the FBI at this point that they are so
desperate to find white supremacists
that they're going to look at the
Catholic church but I think if we're
realistic about it what they're doing is
they have found a Gateway in what they
think is fringe Catholicism in order to
um to move into Christians in general
and and declare them to be the actual uh
the criminals in this country or the
potential terrorists and and that's what
I think we're seeing because this the
whole document basically is written from
the person the perspective of somebody
who thinks that there are significant
abortion rights that need to be defended
and also an LD
lgbtq agenda that has to be pushed down
the American people's throats and those
are antithetical to Catholicism so it's
it's pretty easy it's an Open Door into
Christians in this country which is
pretty much all the country
well yeah and also Orthodox Judaism and
Islam and Mormonism I mean they're right
and now did no one in the FBI say whoa
wait a second it's not our job to decide
which is a better religion and
criminalize people's religious belief
did anyone in your world within the
bureau say that
well obviously The Whistleblower who
brought it to me so I'm in contact with
a number of people who work in the FBI
and have the same values that probably
you and I do and so you know they they
brought it to me one of them brought it
to me and said this is a problem and
this person is not a Catholic uh but he
or she stated the very simple statement
which is that if they're going to go
after radical traditional Catholics then
radical traditional Baptists or necks
and radical traditional evangelicals and
anybody else that espouses essentially
what is radical which is just a
Christian faith and that is uh dangerous
apparently in this country I'm not
Catholic either I'd be defending the
Scientologist or anybody else like you
can't do this yes so I appreciate uh
you're bringing this to to the public
thank you
thanks Docker subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube channel to catch our nightly
opens stories that are changing the
world and changing your life from Tucker
Carlson tonight